paroles et à monsieur jean claude
bouchet merci monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le premier
ministre monsieur le premier ministre
clé clémenceau disait il est plus facile
de réformer autrui que soi même
vous êtes en train de démontrer que vous
ne savez faire ni l'un ni l'autre ni
réformer la france ni apprendre de vos
échecs après alstom énergie alcatel et
lafarge
technip se jette dans les bras d'un
industriel étranger et transfère son
siège social à londres
les fleurons de notre économie continue
de quitter la france l'an dernier 150
nouveaux sièges sociaux se sont
installés au royaume uni dans le même
temps la france en a attiré 11
les chiffres de l'attractivité de la
france font froid dans le dos il
confirme il confirme que la france tout
simplement et tout simplement en
décrochage par rapport à ses voisins
européens les investisseurs
internationaux reviennent en europe mais
pas en france ils vont en allemagne au
royaume-uni
mais la france est exclue de la
compétition pourquoi lorsqu'on les
interroge les investisseurs pointe
évidemment le niveau des charges et des
coûts salariaux
ils redoutent le niveau de la fiscalité
des entreprises il regrette l'absence de
flexibilité dans le droit du travail qui
apparaît chaque jour un peu plus
obsolète
ce recul de la france commande des
vraies réformes pour ne pas laisser le
décrochage s'installer
ces chiffres révèlent votre échec patent
un quinquennat pour rien
le président de la république a raison
ça va mieux né en europe et chez nos
voisins mais ça ne va pas mieux pour les
français qui aujourd'hui ne peuvent même
plus aller travailler du fait de la
pénurie d'essence de la grève des
cheminots
et bientôt des transports en commun
alors monsieur le premier ministre
comment oser dire que ça va mieux qu'en
moins d'un quart des investisseurs
envisagent des projets en france en 2016
allez vous enfin prendre les décisions
qui s'imposent où allez-vous continuer à
laisser la france devenir la risée de
l'europe a persisté dans votre petite
musique du ça va mieux
prenez garde que le peuple de conjuguer
le verbe aller sur tout votre refrain ah
ça ira si la parole et à mesure manuel
macro ministre économique dans
l'industrie du numérique
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les députés
monsieur le député je vais essayer de
reprendre parce que votre question était
très large vous avez finalement couvert
beaucoup de sujets alors d'abord sur
technip
il est faux de dire qu'il s'agit d'une
délocalisation technip a aujourd'hui
fusionnée avec fmc ni même du siège est
fait avec flc qui était l'un de ses
partenaires pour faire en effet un
champion du secteur parapétrolier
qu'elle était sinon la solution
alternative et bien que fmc et technique
soit racheté par les champions anglo
saxons ou norvégiens de ce secteur
c'est ça donc c'est une bonne opération
que nous avons accompagné par le
truchement de la bpi qui est actionnaire
de technip et qui consiste à faire un
champion dont le président exécutif est
un français
le directeur exécutif des opérations est
un français basés en france basé en
france avec deux sièges l'un en france
l'autre à houston là où aujourd'hui le
dirigeant de techniques partagent déjà
son temps entre la france et houston et
avec uniquement un siège juridique qui
est à londres
c'est ça la réalité des opérations c'est
ça la réalité et donc comme le dirigeant
de technip n'a exprimé dimanche
il faut avoir un peu l'esprit de détail
en plus de l'esprit de géométrie
il s'agit d'un airbus du para pétroliers
c'est une bonne chose et c'est une
nécessité
au-delà de cela quand on parle
d'attractivité là aussi monsieur le
député je vous invite à la prudence et
au détail
l'attractivité des sièges sociaux est
une chose ça n'est pas la seule forme
d'attractivité ça n'est pas celle qui
crée le plus d'emplois
c'est la réalité l'attractivité des
sièges sociaux est supérieur au
royaume-uni ou aux pays bas
pourquoi pour des raisons d'optimisation
fiscale ou de gouvernance et c'est une
réalité et il faut la regarder ainsi
nous sommes néanmoins attractif puisque
nous en avons attiré mais moins que ces
pays nous sommes plus attractif en
matière de recherche et développement
nous l'avons montré dans les opérations
récentes et nous sommes plus attractifs
grâce aux dernières décisions en matière
de production
l'attractivité française elle est là et
elle crée de l'emploi
merci la palette à monsieur tomates